en houston como en miami
miles de manifestantes celebraron el
legado de martin luther king juniors
pero la marcha más simbólica tuvo lugar
en washington dc marcada por los
discursos de los miembros de la familia
del asesinado líder de los derechos
civiles el hijo de martin luther king
juniors su esposa y su nieta denunciaron
un derecho al voto bajo ataque en eeuu
hoy mientras estamos aquí
nike 19 estados de la nación han
aprobado leyes para dificultar el voto
para todos los líderes electos que
twittean postean y celebran el día de mi
abuelo el doctor king
mi mensaje hoy es simple no celebren
legisla no
es lo que pide la familia kim después
que un paquete fuera aprobado en cámara
baja el pasado jueves un texto que entre
otros ampliaría el acceso al voto por
correo y reforzaría la supervisión
federal de las elecciones la
vicepresidenta de eeuu cámara haris
también instó al senado a actuar
hoy no debemos ser complacientes ni
cómplices no debemos rendirnos y no
debemos ceder qué va
sabemos que si nos quedamos de brazos
cruzados toda nuestra nación pagará el
precio durante generaciones
las peticiones serán luego que el
presidente yo by done urgiera un cambio
en las normas del senado para evadir el
bloqueo de la minoría republicana sin
embargo dos senadores de su propio
partido se rehusaron a eliminar el
llamado filibuster por lo que aprobar
las leyes que ansían los demócratas
requerirá de al menos 60 votos esto ante
una bancada opositora que controla la
mitad de la cámara alta y que se opone a
ellas mientras avanzan restricciones al
voto en estados republicanos de cara a
las elecciones de medio término de
noviembre